So the correct answer is the third one. So you might have been
tempted to chose the first one here, because it's the shortest. Because you're
trying to respect the fact that Debbie is on the go, and she's
busy, and doesn't have a lot of time to engage with your application. But
actually she'll have to spend more time if you use a notification like
this. She actually has to press the notification, and go into the app to
see what book is overdue and for how long. It actually doesn't really
tell her anything. So in the end this is actually a really bad choice.
The second one might look tempting because it does give her some
more information. But she still has to either launch a navigation app,
if she doesn't know where the library is. She might be really
far away. Or if she wants to extend the books, let's say that
your application allows her to do that, she still has to go
into the app. And that's not really respecting her limited time and
her split attention in with the real world. So the best one,
is the third option. Because in
one glanceable notification, she can completely engage
with your application, and not actually have to enter it. And she has these nice
contextual actions where she can extend the book
or navigate there with just one button press.
>> That was awesome. I did notice one thing,
Debbie is holding her phone with a single hand.
>> yes, that brings us into our next mobile constraint, which is handedness.